Ukrainian soldiers launch American
rounds from a French mortar a team
effort against a common enemy
any moment Russian Artillery near the
Frontline city of bakmut could hit back
they've just fired the guns now we have
to keep low not to give the location
away the Russian line is five kilometers
from here
a fierce battle is Raging on this
freezing front line
as Russia ramps up its attacks
we joined soldiers from Ukraine's third
Brigade in trenches that have turned
Fields into makeshift fortresses over
the past year yeah
come on
a key job of these soldiers is storming
enemy positions
they shared footage from a recent raid
against Russian Mercenaries
one Officer says his troops are
outnumbered but not outclassed it's nice
this is what they're fighting to stop a
creeping Russian Advance that's spilling
over from back moot to the nearby town
of chasivyar
evacuation teams once more on the move
rescuing those too frail to flee
Nina's house was shelled four times
her daughter keeps her company
the next stop is the home of 83 year old
Maria and her husband
once in the minibus her husband offers
his hand
it's all he has left to give
you in the Town Center other families
are waiting to escape like Svetlana and
her seven-year-old daughter
foreign
I've spoken to the mayor he didn't want
to appear on camera but he said that the
situation here is hard but stable yet of
course there are people being evacuated
every day he said many thousands have
left there are still people here though
and the big worry is if back moot's
nearby Falls this place will be next
[Applause]
that's not guaranteed that these
volunteers will certainly be back to
help more families retreat
Deborah Haynes Sky News in eastern
Ukraine